things are not good in the air even now
I'm going to tell you the aqi I just
checked is above 220 that means that
it's very hazardous right now you do see
this Skyline yesterday you couldn't very
hazardous means it affects everybody not
just people with pre-existing conditions
yesterday of course was far worse to
give you an idea the aqi tops at 500 but
yesterday officials here said it reached
484 that's the air quality index which
registered New York as the worst air
quality of any major city in the world
and the greatest risk are young children
the elderly people with pre-existing
conditions but everybody should wear a
mask